No.
Jacob. What? Can you come here?
Is that a line?
Even if it's a faint line,
is that. Is that a faint line, Jacob?
Peter, I think there's, like,
a shadow. I think.
I think that something's on there. That is a paint line.
Well, we're gonna have to take five or six more,
see what happens. No,
it's not. It's not.
It's not real. No,
it's not. I'm not pregnant, Jacob.
There's no way.
I need to get some dimmer lights in here.
Jacob. What?
Jacob, I might be pregnant.
It's possible. Do you think that's why Daisy's been acting weird?
It's possible, babe.
That means we'd have a baby next July.
And I just said that we were gonna.
Right? According to plan.
And I've been telling everybody that we were gonna wait another year,
and I'm. No,
I'm not. I'm in denial.
I don't think it's real. I'm down to be in denial for a little bit.
Okay. But, hey,
I love you no matter what.
And I think if it does happen,
it's God's will, and it's gonna be super awesome. Okay.
Do you think that it's actually positive?
No. You don't think it's actually positive?
Well, okay,
so you're this close to your period.
Um, with our current activities in consideration,
uh, I don't see how it could be that faint of a line if you're truly
are pregnant. Does that make sense?
But they say. Even if it's like. Yeah,
whatever they say, Like,
I'm sure there's a point zero zero one %.
You know, like,
you are pregnant if you have this faint of line.
But I am trying to argue that if you truly are pregnant,
you would truly be pregnant.
Therefore, you truly would have the hormonal markers for that.
And that does not. But the line is there.
And all the other ones we've ever taken,
the line hasn't been there at all. Mm hmm.
You see the line?
Dude, I was just joking.
I just thought I was gonna take a pregnancy test
because I've been feeling, like,
so funny. But I thought it was my period.
My lungs have been so big.
I don't think I'm pregnant.
I don't think you are, either.
Should I take another test?
Yeah, I think you should take it.
Or wait till tomorrow would probably be the best use of spin.
You know, I don't know how much these things cost, but.